ALICIA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: No, this isn't
an anti-feminist statement
from a bygone era.
These are ideas that
are being shared today
in Russia's womanhood schools.
ALICIA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: In her
one-on-one courses,
Alicia offers counseling,
beauty, and styling tips
all with the aim of
creating what she
believes is the ideal woman.
According to Alicia,
women come to her
seeking three main things.
ALICIA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: But according
to Jennifer Utrata,
author of "Women Without Men--
Single Mothers and Family
Change in the New Russia," the
role of women as caretakers
and men as protectors
is not as idealized
as Alicia makes it out to be.
DR. JENNIFER ULTRATA: There's
a longing for a sober, reliable
breadwinner.
NARRATOR: Utrata
interviewed hundreds
of Russian men and women to
understand family life there.
What she found was a
reoccurring problem
within Russian
marriages-- alcoholism.
In 2014, a study indicated
that 25% of Russian males
died before the age of 55,
largely because of alcohol.
As a result, Utrada
noted that women
were being forced to take up the
role of caretaker in the home.
DR. JENNIFER ULTRATA: Studying
families, it is a big problem,
and it would come up
in terms of just not
being able to
count on a partner.
NARRATOR: And among the
women she interviewed,
the idea that the men in
their lives were unreliable
wasn't just down to alcohol.
Unlike the West,
Russian society never
really embraced
feminist ideas that
would encourage men to become
more involved in home life.
During the Soviet era,
women were required to work,
but they were also still
expected to be homemakers.
DR. JENNIFER ULTRATA: With
establishment of the Soviet
Union, equality felt
like more of a slogan
because there was a
movement to really involve
men in domesticity,
childcare, housework.
Women really had
this double burden.
NARRATOR: In modern
day Russia, there
are no rules requiring
women to work.
But under Russian
President Putin's
conservative
government, benefits
that help working women are
not as plentiful as before.
And according to
Utrada, many women
feel like their life
choices are limited.
DR. JENNIFER
ULTRATA: I think one
of the main themes I found
in researching this book
is that there is a
real disappointment
in both Russian men and also
the idea of the government
doing anything for them.
Like it used to
provide these benefits,
and free after-school
programs, and maternity leave.
They can't rely on that anymore.
Literally, almost
every woman said
I can rely on myself alone.
There were a range of
things that they're open to.
They would get support
from their girlfriends
and other women that would help
them keep this focus on relying
on themselves.
NARRATOR: The idea
of self-reliance,
of being the person
within the marriage who
is holding everything
together, is one that
is echoed in Alicia's ideology.
ALICIA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: Of course, not
every woman in Russia
feels the same way as Alicia.
In 2012, the feminist
rock band Pussy Riot
staged an impromptu
concert inside a church
singing lyrics that incited men
and women to become feminists.
They were arrested, but it's
thought that their protest was
one that represented
a growing feeling
among young Russian women
that they were being treated
as second-class citizens.
But inequality surrounding
gender role expectations
in Russia may
continue to permeate
because despite his
policies, it seems
there is an appeal in
Putin to some Russian women
because he appears reliable,
masculine, and more
sober than previous leaders.
And though it may
seem strange to some,
there are a lot of
women like Alicia
who just don't
believe in feminism.
ALICIA: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
NARRATOR: And while
Alicia continues
to school dozens of young
women to be the perfect wife,
she herself remains
unwed, building what seems
to be a thriving business.
In this next episode
over on "Seeker Daily,"
learn more about what life
is like in Russia for women.
SPEAKER 1: And although
women in Russia
are legally allowed
maternity leave, some women
are forced to sign
contracts which
effectively waive their
rights to work in case
they get pregnant.
This is in spite of the fact
that Article 19 of the Russian
Constitution guarantees equal
rights for men and women.
NARRATOR: Thanks
for watching and be
sure to subscribe to Seeker
Stories for new videos
every week.